Magic the Gathering is a card game where
cards are drawn from a deck. And this
naturally introduces a certain amount of
randomness. Sometimes draws are good,
other times they're less good. I imagine
this isn't news to you if you play this
game a lot. Either that or you've had a
luck streak worthy of legend. In the
worst case, you've got the dead card, a
card that you draw and it doesn't do
anything meaningful whatsoever. To some
extent, this sort of draw is just a fact
of life, and it's not something you're
going to be able to fully avoid. Drawing
a land when you don't want one, or not
drawing a land when you do, will always
be a struggle. And though MDFC's utility
lands and other tools can mitigate some
of this unfortunate variance, it will
always be a somewhat present force. But
what about among non-land cards? Well,
the number of non-land draws that end up
being more or less dead can vary
immensely deck to deck. And this number
will often result from the specific
choices that went into the deck building
process. So, in this video, I'm going to
go through the sorts of cards that often
end up being dead draws in a deck and
how to make your deck play more smoothly
without harming the things you enjoy
about it. To start with, let's talk
about an example of a deck with more or
less no dead non-land cards. A deck with
35 swamps and 64 rat colonies. All of
this deck's non-land cards synergize
with each other, and you'll generally
never draw a card and have it be
entirely useless. However, this
obviously comes at a cost. An
exclusively rat colony and swamp deck
has an exceptionally specific game plan
with little to no flexibility. Either a
board with a moderate number of high
power, low toughness creatures wins you
the game or it doesn't. I choose this
example not as a point of aspiration,
but rather as an indication of what
reduces dead draws. These rat colonies
have no variation in the tasks they
perform, all creatures that can beat
down opponents. And they also all
synergize with each other. So, the start
of dead draw mitigation starts by paying
attention to these two things. What does
a card accomplish and what else does it
synergize with? Let's start by
discussing the latter. EDH as a format
encourages synergy. And by synergy, I
simply mean cards doing more together
than they do on their own. This is the
case because the format is 40 life
instead of 20 and has three opponents
instead of one. Conditions that
necessitate that gameplay be
volutrically larger. You simply got to
have more stuff going on. Obviously, the
most simple version of this is the rat
colony example. Your deck is made up of
a creature that will have more power the
more copies of it that are in play. But
this isn't enough volume for a lot of
EDH games. So let's take the example of
a somewhat larger lad. Kyler Sigardian
Emissary. Kyler is a five mana 2 that
gets a plus one plus1 counter whenever
another human enters and gives your
other humans plus one+1 for each of
those counters. So, this is a commander
who can dramatically power up a board of
humans if left unchecked, but whose high
mana cost and small starting stat line
make him a bit of a removal magnet.
Naturally, the primary synergy package
here is humans, but different cards have
different profiles of the situations in
which they're good. Copper Coat Vanguard
is good as long as you have other
humans. Pretty decent assumption for a
humans deck. And also gives the
commander a bit of extra protection.
This card should rarely feel useless and
could even be a pretty solid anthem if
there are tokens out. That brings me to
another card. Increasing devotion is a
large scale token creator and this one
is slightly more complicated in its
power profile. It's fantastic if you
currently have Kyler on board plus some
other humans to swing with. It's decent
if you have some other human ETB effects
on board like loss or knock captain or
champion of the parish in play. also
decent if you have an Anthem at the
ready to pump them up in size and pretty
mediocre if you have none of these
support cards. The flashback prevents it
from ever feeling truly horrible, but it
might be a passable play at best if you
have neither the commander available nor
any of the 15ish cards in the deck that
can amplify this card up to being a
decent play. Most of the popular synergy
cards for a Kyler deck will do things
with humans, and with some exceptions,
most of these will be pretty okay.
However, synergy can go a bit deeper.
You can venture into the magical world
of sub themes. Take plus one plus1
counters. The commander uses them, and
the average Kyler deck has around 12
cards in the 99 that also feature plus
one plus1 counters. So, some players
choose to add metastatic Eve Angel, a
card that proliferates whenever another
non-token creature enters under your
control. Paired with the commander, this
card can turn powerful plays into
utterly earthshattering plays, but it
also doesn't do much to smooth over
Kyler's weaknesses. If he gets removed,
the counters go with him. Put into the
average Kyler deck, this card benefits
12 other cards, which isn't nothing, but
also isn't great. Paired with its
somewhat ephemeral support of the
commander, I'd skip this card
personally. Now, does this mean our
Forexian cleric friend belongs in no
decks? Not necessarily. Some players
might be running larger numbers of plus
one plus1 counter cards than the average
player does, and others might be
building the deck in a way that's likely
to keep Kylo around more of the time.
This card might even be a star player in
some of these decks. It's certainly not
a bad card, but these are the sorts of
considerations you should be making when
you're deciding whether or not to add a
synergy piece. How often will it be in a
situation to support other cards? And
how substantial will that support be?
When I'm building decks, I'll typically
keep track of support for different
themes and sub themes via Architect's
category system. I'll have the baseline
categories I put cards into, but also
secondary categories for things like
Flicker, ETB, Graveyard Enabler,
Graveyard Payoff, and so on. When I'm
adding cards and trying to flesh out a
list, I'll be mostly viewing the deck on
the primary categories tab to keep
things visually neat. But as I start to
prune and sculpt the list, I'll start
bouncing back and forth between that and
the multicategory tab and see if the
various parts of my deck have the right
amount of support. This multicategory
approach is also nice for evaluating
individual cards because I can
immediately see and be reminded of all
of the reasons I included a particular
card, which also indirectly tells me the
situations in which a card will be
useful. As an example, let's take a card
in a subtheheavy Fexian deck I recently
built, that of Rebirth. The categories
here tell me that it's a source of value
that's payoff for having things in the
graveyard. So, as a baseline, I can
check how much stuff I have that helps
me get things into the graveyard with a
focus on creatures since that's what
this can reanimate. However, the other
categories also tell me things about
this card. This card will be stronger
alongside counter amplifiers like
proliferate cards and it'll also be
stronger when I have untap effects on
the field. It's also an artifact and a
lowcost one at that. So, it'll synergize
with several other cards for that reason
alone. And those cards are already
helpfully organized into a category for
me to check on. I can think about all
the other combinations of cards this
card may or may not be on the field
with. And based on that, I can
approximate roughly how often this card
will be useful and roughly how often
this card will be dead. The answer for
this card is that it'll be dead some
modest percentage of the time in the
early game, maybe 25% of the time, but
there are also situations where it'll be
very powerful due to other supporting
pieces being around. So, I've currently
deemed it worth staying in. I also love
the art and flavor of the card, which
does end up being a non-negligible
factor for a lower power deck like this.
So, that's synergies, but that's only
one part of what makes a card dead or
not dead. Another big factor to keep in
mind is what stage of a game a card is
useful in. And before I get into that, I
briefly want to introduce a concept.
Quadrant theory. This sounds
complicated, but it's basically just a
way of analyzing different situations in
which a card could be played. A basic
example goes something like this. We
have this four quadrant box. And in this
case, we'll choose to label the top side
based on the size of an opponent's board
and the left side based on the size of
my board. Now, let's consider the card
teleportal. How is this in different
situations? Well, if we both have small
boards, this card sucks. Not many
creatures to affect and not many
creatures to get past. If I have a small
board and my opponent has a large board,
well, this is still pretty bad. But
maybe there are some niche scenarios
where it lets me get in for the last
couple points of damage after my
opponent has stabilized against my
aggression and it can be cast single
target for two mana in a pinch. If I
have a large board and my opponent has a
small board, well, the unblockable isn't
doing much, but at least I'm getting a
power buff on all my creatures. Where
this card is a straightup banger is when
we both have large boards. This is the
sort of situation where I'm probably
praying for this card as a top deck
since it's getting maximum effect. This
concept was originally designed with
limited formats in mind, where cards are
typically simpler and players tend to be
on the lookout for narrow slivers of
advantage. Fundamentally though,
quadrant theory has a straightforward
and universally applicable purpose. It
exists to make sure that you're thinking
about all of the situations a card might
exist in, not just the ideal ones. A
variant of this might be to analyze a
card based on the stage of the game
we're in. Take a card in a mid-power
deck. How is that card in the early
game? How does it fair in the midame?
Now, decks will typically gain more card
advantage over the course of the game.
So, it's fine to weight your analyses a
bit more heavily toward the later parts
of the game as long as you have the
support to get there. But, you should
still consider different versions of
that late game. There will be the
version of the later game where you're
hitting your stride without setbacks.
But what happens if a board wipe is
played? How about if you have your
board, but your life total has been
taxed heavily by a more aggressive deck?
How about if a mid-range opponent is
pulling far ahead and you need to either
kill some key permanence or heavily
diminish their life total? Different
games will demand different things, and
you should figure out how your different
cards play in those different games. For
a simple example, let's talk about my
rata deck, a deck designed to be as
resilient and consistent with its
gameplay as possible. It typically
curves manador commander into four mana
ramp spell into six and seven drops with
the goal of continuing to ramp and
eventually getting to 20 or more lands.
With that in mind, let's talk about a
couple cards that are present here.
Dracuse m of flames is a seven mana 77
flyer that deals four damage to one
target and three damage to two targets
when it attacks. Oddly, this is a card
that I'm actually most excited to see
early as landing it on turn fourward can
be a pretty backbreaking opener if it
doesn't get removed due to its sheer
power as a removal engine. However, it's
still plenty solid as a top deck later
in the game. What with its good flying
statline and attack ability that remains
respectable even if the creature size
game has been heating up a bit. This
sort of card is a good symbol of what
this deck is best at. It's just always
decent. For an example with a decidedly
different power profile, let's consider
a different card, Captivating Crew. Now,
this card is pretty bad in the early
game. Four mana to threaten an opposing
creature is just never what I want to do
with my mana in the first six turns of
the game, and I'm rarely all that happy
when my turn four or five cascade card
pops out this treason triggering troop
rather than a ramp spell. However, what
keeps me from cutting the card is its
sheer versatility in the late game. As
long as I have enough lands, it almost
always feels good. If I'm ahead on
board, I can pull the last two or three
blockers out from under an opponent and
smack them down before they have the
chance to stall things out. If I'm
behind on board, it often means that I
had a more aggressive but worse scaling
roll out in the early game, in which
case I can often leverage opposing life
totals to get some favorable jump blocks
or at least utilize some abilities on
opposing creatures. If the board is in a
state of parody, it's the best of both
worlds. I can nab my opponent's best
threats and turn a five attacker, five
blocker standstill into an 82 or 91
smackdown. I was a bit hesitant to add
this card to the deck initially, but the
sheer consistency with which it feels
great in the late game has made it one
of my favorite top decks. So far, the
lesson of this video has been more or
less be careful with cards whose use
cases are highly specific. But I can
already hear some of you saying, "But
Alex, I want to play those cards. You're
describing a lot of my favorite cards.
Are you telling me I need to cut those?
And the secret third part of this video
is that you can play those cards and you
can do it fully responsibly. But doing
so requires one specific thing, card
selection. This may be achieved by
playing lots of filtering or by playing
a generally high velocity deck, but the
basic principle is simple. Dead cards
won't matter as long as you simply see
more cards. A basic example of this
might be an ongoing source of filtering
like Muroke Looter. It's not card
advantage, but it doubles the number of
new cards you see each turn and lets you
get rid of any that aren't immediately
useful. Same deal if you play lots of
scry or lots of selective draw. Don't
like the card on top? Ditch it. Don't
want a card in the top four? Great, pick
a different one. This even goes for
actual factual card advantage. If your
deck is consistently able to set up
multiple extra cards per turn in
advantage, that's often going to outpace
your ability to cast what you draw. And
as long as you have more useful stuff to
play instead, there's really no harm in
drawing that situational card. This was
a major fact of life back when I played
a mono black deck in my youth. I'd find
one of my massive sources of draw, and
then suddenly I could cut effortlessly
through the quagmire of redundant pieces
and specific answers that made up the
top of my library. At the end of the
day, all I'm trying to do is make you
aware of the forces at play here. If
your deck feels sluggish or awkward or
swingy, there's a good chance dead cards
are playing a major contributing role in
that feeling. If you frequently find
yourself unable to meaningfully
contribute to a game for stretches of
time, it might be time to audit the
contents of your deck. There are so many
cards that look great and ingrain
themselves in our brains as simply a
part of our deck. Basically, getting to
skip any sort of auditioning process for
simple vibes reasons. I ran don't blink
in my shroom slide deck for several
months because the elevator pitch for it
sounds great. It's a card with cycling
that can also be a big source of removal
if I have astral slide out turning those
exiles into somewhat more lasting
removal. However, when I examined what
this card is actually accomplishing, it
doesn't fit into the desired profile of
a removal spell with cycling at all. I
can cycle it, which is cool when I have
some sort of cycling engine already up
and going. And I can also cast it
normally, which is cool when I have an
even bigger sort of cycling engine
already up and going. Missing entirely
is the part of the card that has any
sort of impact on the game when Astral
Slide isn't in play, outside of wasting
two mana. And as a result, it got cut
for the far superior card, Spectacular
Pileup, when Aether Drift came out. For
a simple exercise, think about the cards
in your deck and try to notice, is there
a card where you seem to be thinking
something along the lines of, "This card
hasn't seen any great games yet, but
it's awesome in theory." If that's the
case, you're going to want to double
check your theories a bit, and take a
longer look at that card. Thanks for
watching, and thanks to my patrons for
supporting the channel, some of whom are
on screen now. I'm actually gearing up
for a cool patron video soon, which will
go something as follows. I'll take card
suggestions from patrons. Then I'll be
running a poll with a bunch of those
cards to determine three of them that
I'll need to construct a deck around.
Then I'll build the deck and put a video
out on my Patreon that details what the
deck does and the process of
constructing it. If you want to be part
of the input for that, you can sign up
for my Patreon for $3 a